[Musik]
Tatort Geldautomat Sprengstoff Gangster
sorgen für Angst und Schrecken fast
täglich knallt es in einer deutschen
Bankfiliale
man hat schon Angst es war ja relativ
nah oft mitten in Wohngebieten Schäden
in Millionenhöhe und Menschen die sich
in Ihren eigenen vier Wänden nicht mehr
sicher fühlen
plötzlich liegt alles in Schutt und
Asche da ist man wirklich am Rande
seiner Existenz
und die Täter kommen immer wieder
[Musik]
Amtsgericht Koblenz Januar 2023
zwei automatensprenger auf der
Anklagebank nur selten werden solche
Täter gefasst sie zeigen was sie von der
deutschen Justiz halten
die beiden Niederländer wurden nach zwei
Spreng versuchen in Deutschland gefasst
einer von ihnen ist Wiederholungstäter
hatte in Deutschland schon mehrere
Millionen Euro Schaden verursacht das
Gericht prüft in den kommenden Tagen die
Beweismittel wird das zu einer
Verurteilung reichen
wenige Kilometer entfernt ein
Einkaufszentrum gegen 2 Uhr nachts
sprengen unbekannte schon wieder einen
Geldautomaten
[Musik]
die Täter Rasen davon Richtung
niederländische Grenze
dabei kommen sie in einem Kreisverkehr
von der Straße ab landen wenige
Kilometer entfernt vom Tatort im
Straßengraben die Insassen flüchten
weiter zu Fuß
einige Stunden später
kriminaloberkommissarin Sabine Weber
gutachtet den Tatort da wo vorher ein
Geldautomat Stand befindet sich jetzt
ein Trümmerfeld
Zerstörung überall das Bild ist hier
natürlich auch schon im Moment sage ich
jetzt mal man sieht hier die
Deckenplatten sind runtergekommen nicht
nur hier sondern auch auf der
gegenüberliegenden Seite bei der
Bäckerei der Schaden dürfte in die
Hunderttausende gehen
die kriminal-oberkommissarin hat schon
viele automatensprenger vor Gericht
gebracht und kommt kaum mit der Arbeit
nach
in den vergangenen Monaten gab es in
Rheinland-Pfalz dutzende Fälle die Täter
setzen immer öfter hochexplosive
festsprengstoffe ein
hier sieht man auch wie stark die
Detonation war also sogar die Außentür
dürfte wahrscheinlich aus der Angel
gerissen gewesen sein und wird jetzt
wieder aufgebaut
ruhegewalt sinnlose Zerstörung die
Polizistin sieht diese Bilder fast
täglich
selbst außen die Tür Schaden beigetragen
hat oder abbekommen hat
so mal die Distanz sieht von Tür zum
Tatort oder zum Geldautomaten selber
sieht man schon eigentlich wie ja was
für einen großen Schaden diese
Detonation anrichten kann dieses Mal
wurde niemand verletzt bei jeder Sprung
haben wir ein hohes Risiko für Dritte
Unbeteiligte Tätergruppierung in diesem
Berufsbereich gehen auch regelmäßig
Wohngebäude an wo sich Familien im
ersten Obergeschoss im zweiten
Obergeschoss befinden die Häuser sind
zum Teil danach ja muss erstmal geprüft
werden ob die einsturzgefährdet sind ja
es besteht nur gefahren und man kann
eigentlich nur von Glück reden wenn den
Anwohner nichts passiert oder was hatten
die vorbeilaufen der Tatort in der Nähe
eine Autobahn ideale Fluchtroute
doch diese Fahrt endete abrupt in einem
Straßengraben
ich bin fast fertig muss ja noch ein
Abrieb nehmen aber dann okay also die
sind wahrscheinlich dann wahrscheinlich
auf dem Kreisel raus herunter die
Spurensicherung ist immer noch vor Ort
ja man sieht ja hier sind hochmotisierte
Autos um die dann zur Flucht genutzt
werden ja die Bergen halt auch die
Gefahr dass man man Unfall baut gerade
mit den Fahndungsmaßnahmen im Raum
stehen mit Hubschrauber gefahren wird
oder mit sonstigen Fahrzeugen
fahndungskräften auf der Straße
in diesem Fall sind die Tatverdächtigen
zu Fuß in ein nahegelegenes Waldstück
geflohen
doch dort entdeckt sie der angeforderte
Polizeihubschrauber
sie werden verhaftet es sind zwei
niederländische Staatsangehörige
von genommen von den
Griffstücken von jetzt wollte ich dir
gerade mal unten drunter gucken was ja
noch drin ist die Polizisten schauen
sich das Fahrzeug ganz genau an
auffällig viele Kanister im Kofferraum
offenbar Sprit für die längere Flucht
ohne Tankstopp das wichtigste ist ja
natürlich jetzt erstmal was finden wir
im Tatfahrzeug gibt es da hebewerkzeug
gibt es da noch zurückgelassene
sprengstoffpakete Kleidungsstücke die
man dann vielleicht später Personen
zuordnen kann die geflüchtet sind wie
man sieht die sind Kennzeichen dann
drauf die können gestohlen sein das
können original Kennzeichen sein dann
gehen natürlich die Ermittlungen zum
Fahrzeug los wo kommt das Fahrzeug her
kann man hier drüber noch Ansätze
gewinnen zur Herkunft der Täter oder
ähnlichen
deutschlandweit gab es 2022
5007 Sprengungen und Sprengversuche an
Geldautomaten ein Anstieg um 29% zum
Vorjahr mit einem jährlichen Schaden von
mehr als 50 Millionen Euro
besonders betroffen ist der besten
Deutschlands
63% der Sprengungen gab es in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Niedersachsen und
Rheinland-Pfalz
Landeskriminalamt Mainz Sabine W und
ihre Kollegen wollen die kriminellen
Strukturen aufdecken verstehen wie die
geldautomatensprenger sich organisieren
haben wir Hinweise auf die auf die
sprengmittelhersteller leider nicht also
Bestand zuerst mal die Vermutung dass in
seiner Beschuldigter auch eventuell für
die sprengpakete zuständig sein könnte
und es besteht eher die Vermutung dass
im Hintergrund jemand die springpakete
beschafft hat um die dann an die Täter
weiterzugeben die Ermittler sind sich
sicher hinter fast jeder
automatensprengung steckt heute ein
großes Team dass die Tat vorbereitet
keine Anfänger hier sind Profis am Berg
ist ein sehr hohe Organisationsgrad da
wir haben eine Führungsstruktur wir
haben eine ausführende Ebene wir haben
hochgradige arbeitsteiliges Vorgehen
wir haben eine Trennung zwischen wie
gesagt den Tätern wir haben keine
Trennung zu den Logistikern zu den
sprengstoffherstellern stellenweise das
ist ein Aspekt der unsinnität auf der
anderen Seite sehen wir auch dass die
Gewinner aus den Taten nicht unbedingt
jetzt
für den eigenen Luxus jetzt verwendet
werden sondern dass die durchaus in
Drogengeschäfte wieder investiert werden
oder aber da bestehen zum Teil auch
Hinweise durchaus in die
Terrorismusfinanzierung fließen können
wie alle Personen so ein bisschen
untereinander verbunden sind und
verletzt sind
und die Verbrecher lernen dazu auf
Schutzmaßnahmen gegen die früherüblichen
gassprengungen haben Sie schnell
reagiert
wir kommen von einer sprechung mit Gas
viele Automaten wurden nachgerüstet mit
gasdetektoren sage ich es mal und was
haben die Täter gemacht sie haben das
Sprengmittel oder den modusoperan die
verändert sie sind zum Fest
sprechenstoff übergegangen mit
entsprechenden Wirkungen und die
sicherer wir die Automaten dann
gestalten lassen oder die Banken die
Automaten gestalten desto höher ist halt
auch der Eintrag von Sprengmitteln oder
der Einsatz wird halt umso gefährlicher
unberechenbarer und so findet
letztendlich ein Bett Lauf statt
nachgewiesen ist dass es in den
Niederlanden gut organisierte
Gruppierungen mit mehreren hunderten
Mitgliedern gibt die für diese Taten
verantwortlich sind werden deren
Handlanger festgenommen Rücken direkt
neue Nachricht
bei dieser Razzia der Polizei Utrecht in
Zusammenarbeit mit deutschen Ermittlern
aus Osnabrück werden neuen Verdächtige
festgenommen
alles Personen aus der organisations-
und Logistik Ebene verantwortlich für 15
Sprengungen in Deutschland die Polizei
stellt verschlüsseltes Smartphones und
Bargeld so wie springutensilien sicher
außerdem eine Art Testlabor indem die
Täter üben können an einem deutschen
Geldautomaten in die Niederlanden
sprengen die Täter nicht nur in
Deutschland und das hat einen Grund
eine Niederlanden ist es tatsächlich so
dass der Tat Anreiz ganz knall hart
weggenommen wird entweder durch das
Entfernen der Automaten oder schließen
zu bestimmten Zeiten oder aber durch das
unbrauchbar machen von Geld und die
Situation haben wir bei uns in der
Bundesrepublik noch nicht und deshalb
zieht das die Täter natürlich
entsprechend an weil sie was das
betrifft hier relativ leichte Spiel
haben im Vergleich zu Niederlanden
noch verzichten viele deutsche Banken
auf bessere Schutzmaßnahmen wohl wegen
der hohen Kosten
höhergrenzhausen im Westerwald bereits
dreimal waren hier automatensprenger am
Berg die Lage verkehrsgünstig an der A48
oberkommissarin Sabine W will heute
Augenzeugen treffen
die Wucht war sehr groß das sieht man
auch am Schadensbild also es sind
Splitter geflogen bis dort drüben in den
Garten
und auch hier die Straße gut befahren so
dass ich hier schon von der hohen
Gefährdung für Dritte ausgehe also die
Splitter die über die Straße geflogen
sind hätten vorbeifahren das Fahrzeug
treffen können und jetzt auch schlimmer
ausgehen können der Sachschaden fast
eine Million Euro er beutet haben die
Täter aber nur knapp 2000 €. drei
Sprengungen waren dafür nötig die
weckten die gesamte Nachbarschaft
weswegen ist einige Augenzeugen und
ungewöhnlich viel Videomaterial gibt
wie geht es den Anwohnern jetzt Sabine W
besucht einen Zeugen der aus einiger
Entfernung ein Video der Täter machte
drei vermummte Leute die da hektisch
soll jetzt mal hin und her gelaufen sind
zwischenzeitlich ist dann auch noch ein
weißes Auto so ins Sichtfeld die
Straßenstück runtergerollt dass dann
jemand hin gelaufen hat noch irgendwas
aus dem Auto rausgeholt und kurz darauf
gab es halt noch mal eine dritte
Explosion wo dann wirklich noch mal
richtig man den Staub und so gesehen hat
[Musik]
Raban s wohnt in direkter Linie zur Bank
dreimal haben die Täter hier in den
vergangenen Jahren zugeschlagen langsam
bekommt er es mit der Angst zu tun ob
die jetzt ihre Sprengstoffmenge richtig
geraten haben ja und ob dann vielleicht
doch irgendwelche Metallteile bis hier
noch da drüben bei uns fliegen oder
irgendwelche von den Nachbarn da
irgendwas abbekommen
und noch näher dran war kein so ey er
möchte unerkannt bleiben aus Furcht vor
den Automaten springen
der Fluchtwagen stand direkt hier vorne
zurückgefahren ja
und dann ist ein Täter noch mal
rausgelaufen hat aus dem Wagen irgendwas
geholt gehabt
ja meinst du wieder reingelaufen und
dann ging es eigentlich blitzschnell
alles da wurde noch
rumgeschrien auf Holländisch hat noch
richtig gehört das Rolle nicht wahr Ken
so wohnt nur wenige Meter von der Bank
entfernt in der Tatnacht hat er im
Reflex aus nächster Nähe gefilmt
gehabt und hat mich schon gesehen gehabt
aber das hatte ich gar nicht
interessiert
so weiter gemacht
dann hat man keinen Erbarmen für nichts
ne dann wollen die Leute einfach
ihre Sache durchziehen auch nach der
Flucht der Täter lief Kansas Kamera
weiter
guck mal Alter
zu diesem Zeitpunkt liegen noch nicht
die trainierte springsätze vor der Bank
und kennen so direkt daneben
ja ist halt ein komisches Gefühl wenn
man so zurückdenken tut und was für eine
Gefahr ist da stand ne
kriegt man schon ein bisschen
Bauchschmerzen ehrlich gesagt vielen
Anwohnern wird die Bedrohung erst danach
bewusst die Polizeibeamtin trifft viele
Betroffene die von enormen psychischen
Belastungen berichten
es gab tatsächlich eine Zeugin die genau
über der Bankfiliale gewohnt hat die aus
dem Ausland stammt und ja die auch
Erfahrung hatte mit ja ich denke mal
Krieg oder ähnlichem und die hatten wir
ein Jahr später mit hatten wir mit ihr
noch mal das Gespräch und die waren auch
richtig traumatisiert also die wollte
gar nicht über das Ereignis reden ist ja
sicherlich schwer gefallen und ja das
zeigt dann schon was für ein Ausmaß das
haben kann nicht nur für ein Gebäude für
den Schaden sondern auch für die Person
die da im Umfeld leben traurig zu sehen
die rücksichtslosität er da vorgehen und
den das ziemlich egal ist ob da jemand
drüber wohnt schläft das kann ja auch
ein Kind drüber wohnen was dann ja
ziemlich lange Schaden davon tragen
könnte
2022 gab es in Rheinland falls die
drittmeisten Sprengungen Deutschlands
auffällig sie fanden fast ausschließlich
in der Nähe von Autobahnen statt auch
eine Sprengung vor einigen Monaten in
der Gemeinde Gensingen passt in dieses
Muster
gerade die Lage direkt hier entlang der
einen 60 der gerade durch
Rheinland-Pfalz führt und auch
Verbindungsweg ist zu den Niederlanden
ist das hier ein präsenierter Ort für
eine geldautomatensprengung und können
somit halt schnell vom Tatort flüchten
ohne dass die Polizei in der rankommt
auch hier waren Anwohner in Gefahr eine
von ihnen Eileen s sie wohnt nur wenige
Meter von der Bank entfernt
dann habe ich halt eine Person hier
rauslaufen gesehen und steigt dann
hinten ins Auto ein beim Fahrer hinten
und fuhr dann auf mich los nur durch
einen Sprung zur Seite kann sich Eileen
es retten in Ihrer Straße in direkter
Nähe zum Geldautomaten fühlt sich die
zweifache Mutter nun nicht mehr sicher
man geht jeden Abend mit dem schlechten
Gefühl ins Bett ja und man hat halt
nachts dann schon Angst
nach Hause zu laufen wenn man bei
Freunden ist oder auf dem Geburtstag
eingeladen ist also man geht bewusster
glaube ich jetzt hier durch die Straßen
auch tagsüber muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen meine Kinder sage ich auch immer
halt die Augen auf passt auf Euch auf
macht langsam genau ja
ein Schock war die automatensprengung
auch für die Ärztinnen Martina drinnen
Berg und Angela minor in Mainz die
Sprengung des benachbarten Geldautomaten
zerstörte ihre Praxis gleich mit
da bin ich knietief erstmal in Trümmern
gewartet die Decke die abgehängte Decke
die war völlig auf dem Boden runter
gestürzt und man kann sich das jetzt
kaum vorstellen wenn man hier die Räume
sieht außerdem war noch ganz viel
glasplitter zu sehen die Tür war kaputt
die ein Teil der Tür lag auf den
Eisenbahnschienen
Wiederaufbau von Praxis und Inventar
haben mehrere 10.000 € verschlungen ein
Kraftakt für die Ärztinnen
völlige existenzangs ich war gerade
sechs Monate dabei habe mich
niedergelassen hat mich selbstständig
gemacht habe viel Geld investiert und
plötzlich liegt alles in Schutt und
Asche da ist man wirklich am Rande seine
seiner Existenz noch gibt es in
Deutschland keine gesetzliche Pflicht
bestimmte Sicherungssysteme in
Geldautomaten einzubauen doch die Banken
stehen unter Druck
es werden Menschenleben gefährdet wenn
Existenzen gefährdet und
letztendlich ja reden die Banken sicher
raus muss man sagen dabei ist ein
höheres Maß an Schutz oft möglich aber
das kostet in dieser Sparkassenfiliale
im saarländischen Heusweiler haben es
die automatenknacker vor wenigen Wochen
versucht doch kurz vor der Sprengung
sind sie ohne Beute geflohen
die hebelspuren sind noch deutlich zu
erkennen hier wurde dann der Hebel
angesetzt stimmweise das kann man sehr
gut erkennen hier an diesen beiden
Stellen wie das Brecheisen dort
angesetzt wurden ist seit 2017 hat die
Sparkasse Saarbrücken fast eine Million
Euro in ihre rund 100 Automaten gesteckt
mit Erfolg in sechs Jahren gab es nur
noch einen einzigen erfolglosen Versuch
einer Sprengung die Automaten anderer
saarländischer Banken wurden im selben
Zeitraum 21 mal attackiert die Sparkasse
setzt zur Abschreckung auf ein System
mit Farbkartuschen in den Geldkassetten
sind also zwei Bereiche in dem vorderen
Bereich hier drin sind die Geldscheine
die sind so entsprechend aufgestaffelt
und werden hier vorne aus der Kassette
rausgegeben und hier hinten sieht man
das hinten färbes System und dieses löst
wenn die Kassette halt eben scharf
geschaltet ist sie wird rausgezogen es
gibt eine Erschütterungen Explosion löst
diese Patrone aus das heißt die
explodiert und färbt von hinten kommt
nach vorne alle Geldscheine so durch
damit halt eben der entsprechende Täter
wirklich nur komplett durchgefärbte
Scheine erhalten würde mit denen er im
Grunde genommen überhaupt nichts mehr
anfangen kann
ca 8000 Euro kostet diese Nachrüstung
pro Automat das Problem in Deutschland
gibt es über 50.000 Geldautomaten die
oft nicht optimal gesichert sind
deswegen kommen die Täter aus den
Niederlanden hierher und Sabine W hat
immer neue Fälle auf dem Tisch
man kann ein paar Ansätze erlangen mit
was für einer Gruppierung man es zu tun
hat ob es vielleicht die gleichen oder
ähnliche Täter sein dürfen wir an einem
anderen Tatort aber von überführen kann
man hier nicht reden einfach weil
mittlerweile die Täter so stark vermummt
sind also die kleinen Sturmhauben
manchmal haben die auch diese
Regenanzüge alle gleichermaßen an
meistens auch Socken bis zur Hosen man
hat eigentlich gar keinen Körper mehr
der rausschaut sage ich jetzt mal wo man
später sagen kann genau der war jetzt
auch wirklich am Tatort die Täter
attackieren hier zwei Geldautomaten er
wollten jedoch nur knapp 2000 €. die
Überwachungskamera wird bei der
Sprengung zerstört die Aufgabe der
Ermittlerin alle Puzzleteile Hinweise
und Erkenntnisse der Spurensicherung
zusammenführen dabei helfen auch Videos
von Zeugen
man kann sehen dass einer von den Eltern
hier im Fluchtfahrzeug wartet und die
Straße müssen auf und abfährt aber
darüber hinaus gibt es hier verschiedene
Zeugen die Filmen und die Täter lassen
sich eigentlich nicht aus der Ruhe
bringen also die machen weiter die gehen
in die Bank machen so lange weiter bis
sie das Geld erlangen und steigen dann
erst ein und flüchten
das Fahrzeug lassen die
automatensprenger später an einem
anderen Ort zurück es handelt sich um
einen Mietwagen ein Glücksfall für die
LKA Ermittlerin ist der verbaute
GPS-Sender der macht den ganzen Weg der
Täter präzise nachvollziehbar
also man sieht hier dass die Täter
insgesamt aus den Niederlanden gekommen
sind also Startpunkt in den Niederlanden
war anhand dieser
türkisenfarbewegung ist dann zu sehen
dass die Täter hier im Grenzgebiet nicht
über die Autobahn nach Deutschland
eingereist sind sondern hier die Strecke
über die grüne Grenze genutzt haben das
ist eigentlich üblich für so
Tätergruppierung einfach um irgendwie
konspirativ nach Deutschland einzureisen
und ja ein fahndungskräften zu entgehen
auf ihre Flucht sind die
automatensprenger aggressiv und kuppelos
riskieren Menschenleben
man muss immer bedenken dass höchstes
Ziel der Täter ist erstens ans Geld zu
kommen und dann aber auch nach Hause zu
kommen ohne von der Polizei gefasst zu
werden und so agieren die auch also nach
einer Tat kam schon öfter vor dass wenn
eine Polizeistreife die gesehen hat dass
die Täter trotzdem losfahren das
Polizeifahrzeug weggraben und einfach
vom Tatort flüchten
ihr Ziel die Grenze Richtung Niederlande
oder Belgien dabei werden sie immer
wieder auch von polizeihubschraubern
verfolgt
mit den hochmutisierten Fahrzeugen ist
halt schwer mit einem Polizeiauto da
dran zu kommen gerade auch weil die
Täter ein ziemlich rücksichtsloses
Fahrverhalten zeigen
Geschwindigkeiten bis 300 km/h überholen
rechts überholen links das ist einfach
nur eine Gefährdung für die Polizei
Einsatzkräfte und wenn man da bei einer
Verfolgung dran bleibt auch eine
Gefährdung für unbeteilte Dritte auch
nach einem Unfall selbst in der airberg
ausgelöst ist so eine Tat hat mir auch
mal und die Täter im Graben liegen
flüchten trotzdem fußläufig egal ob die
verletzt sind oder nicht
dieses wärmebild-video entsteht nach
einer Sprengung in Kierspe in NRW der
Fluchtwagen Rast über einen nagelgurt
der Polizei die Täter flüchten zu Fuß
weiter verstecken sich in diesem
Waldstück werden schließlich von
Spezialeinheiten festgenommen
hi darf ich euch ja in Sabine wees
aktuell im Fall gibt es etwas Neues
wichtige Beweisstücke vom Tatort die
Spezialisten waren schon dran ich komme
wegen der sprengen höher ich habe gehört
was vor Ort
Schuster ist ein schärfer im LKA er war
direkt nach der Sprengung in der Bank
und hat zwei Pakete sichern können wir
haben im Bereich des Eingangs neben
einem Weg gelegen zum Eingang der der
Bank die waren wahrscheinlich als
Reserve noch gedacht die haben wir dort
gefunden sind unsere typischen
sprengpakete sehen sehr gut vom Aufbau
aus sehr professionell wir haben hier
wieder unsere typisches rausklebeband
auch und
die glänzende Plastikhülle kommt von der
Polizei darunter mit Klebeband
umwickelter Sprengstoff
was passieren können das Problem ist
immer wir wissen nie wie genau der
Aufbau der springpakete ist welche
Zünder verbaut ist welche exklusivstoff
ist verbaut von daher müssen wir uns
immer auf einer hohe Gefährlichkeit
einstellen wir haben oft selbstlaborate
die verwendet werden und die sind sehr
empfindlich gegen Druck von daher doch
eine hohe Gefährdung auch für
unbeteiligung einfach mal da vorbei
laufen die sprengpakete werden nun auf
Fingerabdruck und dNA Spuren untersucht
ich würde es bei euch lassen dass ihr es
dann hoch geben kann genau
die sogenannten selbstlaborate der
automatensprenger können gewaltige
Explosionen auslösen Sabine W bekommt
regelmäßig Videos aus
Überwachungskameras auf den Tisch hier
attackieren zwei Täter einen
Geldautomaten in einem freistehenden
Pavillon
man sieht dann hier wie beide Täter an
dem Geldautomaten hebeln
brutal zielgerichtet geübt die Banden
wissen genau wo sie ansetzen müssen sie
benötigen nur wenige Minuten bringen den
Sprengstoff an und den Geldautomaten zu
Explosion
eine andere Tat dieselbe professionelle
Vorgehensweise im Vorraum sieht man die
Täter legen sich zwei springpakete
bereit Kabel zünden den Sprengstoff aus
der Entfernung
auf einer anderen kamera-perspektive
kann man dann sehen wie nach der
Detonation sich einen Täter auch in der
Bank befindet man sieht niemenses
Schadensbild zum Teil sind die Gebäude
auch schon einsturzgefährdet und die
Täter begeben sich trotzdem in den Raum
um das Bargeld dann aufzusammeln wenn es
zu einer erfolgreichen Sprengung kam
wieder und wieder schaut sie die Filme
und entdeckt manchmal entscheidendes bei
dieser geldautomatensprengung ist uns
dieser Schuh hier aufgefallen auch
abgebrütetäter machen Fehler
und zwar bei einer anderen
geldautomatensprengung weniger Wochen
zuvor konnte man beim einem der Täter
ebenfalls einen solchen Schuh
feststellen und auch im Rahmen der
Ermittlung hat sich dann weiter
bestätigt dass es sich hierbei um die
gleiche Tätergruppierung gehandelt hat
die dann tatsächlich von uns auch später
festgenommen werden konnte immer wieder
aber ist auch die
oberkommissarinfassungslos
man sieht hier unten wieder eine Täter
sogar auf dem festbrennstoffpaket was da
bereit liegt tritt und das gleich auch
aus Versehen zur Seite gekickt also
jetzt zeigt sich das eigentlich schon
dass die Täter umgehen können mit den
Pferden stoffpaketen also die machen das
öfter die können ein bisschen
einschätzen wie sie mit den umzugehen
haben dass sie für sie selber nicht
gefährlich sind was aber nicht heißt
dass wenn eine Detonation erfolgt das
nicht für unbeteiligte Dritte gefährlich
sein kann
bei aufgerüsteten Automaten reicht eine
Sprengung oft nicht aus hier wird ein
zweites sprengpaket angebracht
nur wenige Sekunden nachdem der
rausläuft kommt es direkt hier zu
Detonation also der hat noch nicht lange
überhaupt die Bank Filiale verlassen
hier sieht man dann dass der Täter
tatsächlich auch in den Geldautomaten
rein krabbelt die haben da eigentlich
gar keine Angst die wollen einfach nur
ans Geld und den ist auch egal wenn er
Zeugen vor der Tür stehen auch andere
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen der Banken
werden schnell überwunden bei dieser Tat
sieht man einen der Täter die
Glasscheibe ja einschlagen das
eigentlich auch typisch bei
professionellen Gruppierungen dass die
sich nicht von der verschlossenen
Schiebetür oder so behindern lassen also
die Hebeln die aufschlagen die ein und
verschaffen sich dann trotzdem zutrifft
zu der Bank Filiale
es findet ein Wettrüsten zwischen Banken
und automatensprengern statt manche
Sicherheitssysteme funktionieren
ist die Nebelmaschine von der Bank
Filiale löst aus der ganze Bankraum wird
mit Nebel gefüllt und die Täter
verlassen hier in dem Fall dann die Bank
Filiale das aber nicht immer so es gibt
auch genug Gruppierungen die dann
trotzdem noch die Tat vollziehen und das
zeigt halt so ein bisschen wie abgebrüte
sind also sie lassen sich davon nicht
immer abschrecken
früher wurde hauptsächlich Gas in die
Automaten eingeleitet und zur Explosion
gebracht die Schäden am Inventar waren
groß
am Gebäude aber vergleichsweise gering
und viele Nachahmer wollten am modernen
Bankraub mitverdienen so wie diese
beiden Amateure bei dieser Tat kann man
zwei Täter sehen und die führen einen
Trolli mit dem sich Gasflaschen befinden
was so nicht typischerweise ist für die
professionellen Tätergruppierung Gas und
versprengstoff am Anfang eine andere
sprengenwirkungen Schadenbild ist ein
unterschiedlich und die ja der Erfolg an
den das Geld auch zu kommen wir sehen
hier wie Täter nun eine Zündspule gegen
und dann kommt es zur Sprengung des
Geldautomaten
hier sieht man dass der Geldautomat
tatsächlich mal geöffnet wurde
weil sogenannten nachahmen ist
eigentlich so dass die eher weniger
erfolgreich sind meistens mehrere Male
bis überhaupt zu mir kommen und auch
wenn sie zum Erfolg kommen
bzw meistens so dass irgendwelche Spuren
hinterlassen
einige Wochen später endlich gute
Nachrichten für Sabine weh zwei
Tatverdächtige konnten in Belgien
festgenommen werden kurz nachdem sie in
Rheinland-Pfalz zwei Geldautomaten
attackiert haben einer von ihnen scheint
ein Serientäter zu sein
spricht schon dafür dass das eine Person
ist die regelmäßig ja mit der Begehung
von Sprengungen versucht sein
Lebensunterhalt zu finanzieren der sich
darauf spezialisiert hat das zeigt auch
die schnellen Autos die Maskierung bei
bei der Fahrt zum Beispiel wir haben
hier ein blitzerbild von dem
tatfahrzeugen und auch die Gegenstände
die im Bereich von dem Tatfahrzeug
aufgefunden wurden diese Fundstücke
wurden von der belgischen Polizei
bereits nach Mainz geschickt
dann haben wir
sprengkabel sichergestellt im Auto war
ja noch ein sprengpaket was wir jetzt
auch untersuchen lassen haben im Tatort
im Abgleich dann haben wir einen Anzug
wir haben auf dem Videos haben wir auch
einen Täter der so ein Hema Anzug an
hatte und dann haben wir noch das
Brecheisen das ist eigentlich ganz gut
man sieht nämlich hier so die silberne
Spitzen und ich glaube die kann man auf
dem Video am Tatort aussehen
ja und dann hier natürlich das Kabel
das wurde im Auto sichergestellt
war ja auch noch ein Paket im Auto
zurückgeblieben und am Tatort in Ulmen
gibt's auch springkabel so dass das
abgeglichen wird ob das zusammenpasst
Sabine W arbeitet in solchen Fällen eng
mit der Staatsanwaltschaft Mainz
zusammen die später Anklage erheben wird
und was steht dann jetzt noch aus ah
Durchsuchung
sind durchgeführt Ergebnisse habe ich
leider noch keine aber sobald ich da die
Berichte bekomme informiere ich Sie
natürlich ja
einige Wochen später die zwei
Niederländer stehen in Koblenz vor
Gericht die Beweise haben ausgereicht
die beiden 24-Jährigen sind schuldig der
Herbeiführung von Sprengstoffexplosionen
außerdem Diebstahl und Sachbeschädigung
die Strafe drei Jahre und 11 Monate für
den einen 5 Jahre für den anderen Täter
Sabine W kann zufrieden sein an diesem
Tag
das ist natürlich gut zu sehen wenn wir
jetzt Täter vor Gericht hat wo man weiß
dass sie schon langejährige an diesem
Bereich zu verordnen sind gerade im
Bereich von geldautomatensprengung
dass die jetzt vor Gericht sitzen und
dann hoffentlich auch inhaftiert werden
für längere Zeit um einfach weitere
Taten durch diese Täter zu verhindern
doch die nächsten stehen schon in den
staatlichen
denn solange sie hier in Deutschland
leicht und schnell an Geld kommen die
automatensprenger immer wieder zurück